Musik
Vielen Dank an Lukas für dieses fantastische Intro, schön, dass ihr wieder da seid beim Podcast-UFO. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, das Podcast-UFO Heute ist Folge 165. Und du weißt, was das heißt? Die Kreditkartensperrnummer 165165, falls ihr eure Kreditkarte verloren habt, ruft an bei 165165. Ist nicht so einfach zu merken, um ehrlich zu sein. Alles ist einfacher zu merken als 165165. Ich glaube, du musst ja auch gucken, welche Nummern noch frei sind. 110 ist schon weg, 112 und dann Giftnummer ist glaube ich 113. Schlangenalarm ist 114. Die trennen Schlangen und Gift? Rauch, aber kein Feuer ist 115, damit die mit ihren grossen Rauchstaubsaugern kommen, damit die wissen, was das ist. Feuer, aber ist nicht so schlimm, weil ich wollte es eh verbrennen, Osterfeuer und sowas ist 119. Achtung, wir grillen nur 118, ganz klassisch. Und dich halt hochrechnen bis zur 1,6,5. Ich glaube, ich war der erwachsenste Moment in meinem Leben, als ich meinem Bankautomaten Geld abgehoben habe. Und dann stand da so, falls Sie Ihre Nummer verlieren, Ihre Karte verlieren, 1,6,5, 165, habe ich ein Foto gemacht. Weil ich mir dachte, vielleicht komme ich mal in die Situation, in der ich diese Nummer brauche. Und das ist für mich das, was Erwachsen sein heißt. Auch mal vorausdenken, auch mal Pläne für die Zukunft machen und zu sagen, wo geht's hin, in welche Situation könnte ich geraten und was würde mir dann helfen. Hast du das Gefühl, dass du umsichtiger wirst, schlauer wirst, reflektierter wirst, oder hast du genau wie ich das Gefühl, dass man langsam abbaut? Ja, ich baue total ab. Ich baue ab. Total, meine Aufmerksamkeit sparen ist eine Katastrophe. Ich habe mittlerweile immer häufiger das Gefühl, dass ich nicht weiß, was ich gerade machen wollte. Ja, und auch nicht weiß, was ich gerade mache. Also manchmal verliert man sich so, oft guckt man irgendwie, surft man rum im Netz und dann plötzlich setzt das Gehirn an und fragt einen auch so, sag mal ganz kurz, das ist das, was wir gerade machen? Ich meine, ich frage nur, ich bin nur der der Fragensteller, okay? Ich bin nur der Fragensteller, ich wollte nur mal fragen, ob das wirklich das ist, was wir machen. Ja, aber kennst du dieses Gefühl, dass wenn du surfst und dir fällt was ein, ah, auf die Website könnte ich noch gucken oder dieses Video könnte ich noch anschauen und dir baut sich diese Vorfreude auf und dann verlierst du aber den Gedanken, aber die Vorfreude bleibt. Also du hast so ein Disconnect zwischen Grund für Emotion und Emotion und du hast noch diese Vorfreude in dir und dann dann denkst du, ah geil, ich wollte doch jetzt noch, ah was. So sehr kann ich mich nicht manipulieren. Was mir häufig so passiert bei YouTube, muss man sagen, der Algorithmus ist schon richtig gut. Also da werden schon Videos angezeigt, die man richtig gerne sehen will. Dann habe ich aber mittlerweile diese Später-Ansehen-Funktion so sehr für mich entdeckt, dass ich sage, nee, das Video, da habe ich jetzt so viel Bock drauf, das gucke ich mir später an.
Jetzt ist nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt. Also ich teile mir bewusst ein, was für eine Art, ich hatte auch die letzten drei Tage frei und ich habe das seit einem Jahr nicht mehr gehabt und ich wusste gar nicht, wie man mit dieser Zeit umgeht. Und ich habe dann bei YouTube, als ich dann so YouTube-Zeit mir eingeräumt hatte, habe ich dann wirklich dann manchmal einfach mir die Zeit eingeteilt, in der ich jetzt dieses Video gucken will, in der ich diese Art von Spaß haben will, in der ich informativen Spaß haben will, so eingeteilt. Wie absurd man da mittlerweile auch mit der Unterhaltung spielen kann. Total, ich fahre ja immer viel Zug und für die Zugfahrt lade ich mir immer Videos runter, weil ich im Zug kein Internet habe und das ist eigentlich die beste Möglichkeit, YouTube zu konsumieren, sich bewusst Videos runterzuladen, die dann auf der Festplatte zu haben und dann auch nur die anzuschauen und dann ist auch Schluss. Dann hast du genau das. Und du hast nicht diese Rated Videos, aber naja, ich verbringe bestimmt noch genauso viel Zeit noch. Normalerweise, ich muss gleich weg, ich muss gleich in die Maske, da muss ich schon mal vorbauen. Ich muss gerade angefangen. Ich muss eine kleine Pause machen um 45, in sechs Minuten muss ich weg. Musst du weg? Da muss ich kurz in die Maske. Du bist ja in der Express-Express-Folge. Nee, ich komme ja danach wieder zurück. Was denkst du dir denn, dass ich denn hier warte oder was? Ich bin Stefan Tietze. Kannst du mal alleine und kannst du mal ein bisschen was aus dem Privatleben. Dann habe ich Stefan Tietze. Hast du nicht jetzt auch ein Buch geschrieben? Nee, aber was ich mich frage, viele Leute, Freunde von uns haben jetzt auch Bücher rausgebracht. Zum Beispiel Julia Becker, fantastisches Buch. Das Leben ist eines der härtesten, genau. Hol's euch, Sophie Passmann, Buch geschrieben, haut's euch. Die grösste Kritikerin deines Buches, Julia, ist übrigens meine Mutter, die gesagt hat, oh, das Leben ist eines der härtesten von einer Mitte-20-Jährigen, toll. Die schon derweil erlebt zu haben. Was? Du kannst nicht einfach davon ausgehen, dass Leute den Podcast hören. Du kannst dich Leute direkt ansprechen. Du, Julia, pass mal auf, jetzt wo ich dich gerade habe. Wo wolle ich gerade miteinander reden? Ich habe meinen Schar leider vergessen im Redaktionsraum. Kannst du mir den morgen mitnehmen? Nee, weil das ganz interessante intime Ansprache war. Aber ich war sehr stolz auf, warum auch immer, auf Julia und auf Sophie, weil die tolle Bücher geschrieben haben und ich habe mich sehr für die beiden gefreut. Und Julia direkt abgeräumt, Lit Cologne Preis gewonnen? Debütpreis gewonnen, mega cool. Ich würde auch so gerne mal einen Preis gewinnen. Er muss ja was dafür machen. Wie das sein muss, du stehst dann auf so einer Bühne. Kann mir gar nicht vorstellen. Kann mir gar nicht vorstellen. Und dann Preis gewinnen, aber nee, was wolltest du sagen? Ich wollte nur sagen, dass sehr viele in unserer Blase befindliche Menschen bei Instagram, bei Twitter diese Bücher empfohlen haben und gesagt haben, alle gesagt haben, das ist ein sehr gutes Buch, lese das Buch. Aber ich bin noch nicht durch. Ich würde es ja auch gerne machen. Ich brauche aber halt bestimmt noch drei Jahre für das Buch. Du willst nicht was empfehlen, was du noch nicht beendet hast. Nee, also wahrscheinlich meine Empfehlung ist nicht böse gemeint, Julia, wo wir gerade hier so gemeinsam miteinander reden, sondern wahrscheinlich kommt es erst in einem Jahr. Ich glaube, das sind sogar die wertvolleren Kritiken, die dann so die zweite Stürme machen. Dass ein Buch sich gut verkauft, wenn es rauskommt, ist ja erstmal klar. Gerade wenn irgendwie die Autorin eine gewisse Prominenz hat und viele das dann retweeten. Aber das Problem ist ja, dass es relativ schnell abflacht wieder. Und ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Hype-Punkt macht es auch keinen Unterschied mehr. Wenn mal Jan Böhrmann Werbung gemacht hat, ist es egal, ob du jetzt auch noch Werbung machst. Weil niemand folgt dir, der nicht auch Jan Böhrmann folgt. Und deswegen ist es besser, dass erst mal Jan Böhrmann, alle gucken, ah okay, dann kauf die Hälfte das Buch und dann drei Wochen später haust du noch mal einen Tweet raus und dann alle, ah stimmt, ah jetzt habe ich Internet, jetzt ja ins Jahr. Wahrscheinlich kommt mein Tweet, wenn das Buch gar nicht mehr zu kaufen ist, aber wenn der dritte Teil Teil draußen ist und du noch mal sagst, ey Leute, ich habe hier ein Buch gefunden. Der erste war mega, schon lange irgendwie Pulitzerpreis. Ja, aber da, also du lest es unbedingt, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es ist, um ehrlich zu sein. Es ist ja so ein Ding, ich bin oft in Büchereien, gerade an Bahnhöfen, wenn ich auf Züge warte, und da merkt man immer den ganz großen Unterschied zwischen Erwachsenenbüchern und Kinderbüchern. Weil Kinder sind ja dumm, die muss man ja durch irgendein Gimmick einangeln. Die sind ja wie so ein dummer Fisch, die dann irgendwie so einen Blinker wollen und dann kriegt man die. Das heißt, jedes Buch, jede Kinderbuchautorin und Autor muss sich irgendwas überlegen. Manchmal sind die Seiten an der Seite so golden oder da ist was drin oder es hat so einen Pelz obendrauf. Und wirklich, du siehst einfach, wenn du durch das Kinderbuchregal schaust, die abnehmende Kreativität. Weil so ab der Hälfte, so bei Buchstabe C, bei Christina Gürgensen, merkst du schon, Leute, wir haben einfach keine Fakten Ideen mehr. Hier ist eine gratis Lupe drin, so. Ja, da ist eine Schatzkarte hinten drin. Es funktioniert einfach nicht mehr. Die besten Ideen wurden gemacht und dann haben die so ganz merkwürdige Formate auch und dann sieht das Papier so aus, als wäre es halb verbrannt.
Was ist hier eigentlich los? Also ohne Scheiß, hier sind sämtliche Leitungen gerade angesprungen.
Ist hier ein Klo? Wir mussten uns leider zurückziehen, wir nehmen heute am Tag die Neo-Magazin-Aufzeichnung auf. Wir sind geflohen in die Tonkabine, während die Sendung vorbereitet wird gerade, deswegen muss ich auch gleich noch waschen. Hi Tom, hey. Ach Gott, niemand war so oft im Podcast wie Tom. Wie fucking Ton Tom. Was hat man für eine Frisur? Ich finde es ganz toll, dass man hier durchgucken kann, aber die einen nicht hören kann. Aber wir haben so ein kleines Fensterchen. Also wir sitzen sehr eng aufeinander, Körper reiben sich aneinander. Aber ich trage Schutzkleidung, das ist eigentlich ganz schön. Aber du trägst deine, wie rein oder egal, Schoner. Ja. Ja. Nee, worauf du gerade angespielt hast, wir wollen uns sehr herzlich bedanken für den Podcastpreis, den deutschen Podcastpreis, der in Essen verliehen wurde. Thais war für uns am Start. Vielen Dank an Thais, sie wollte eigentlich eine mitreißende William-Wallace-eske Rede halten, ja, um die ganze Truppe zu motivieren, irgendwie die alten Medien zu verbrennen. Sie hatte leider nicht die Möglichkeit dazu, das kann ich jetzt aber auch noch selber erzählen, vielleicht kriegt sie noch Sinn, einen Beitrag darüber zu machen, was sie da erlebt hat auf dem Podcast. Ich habe mir eigentlich eine Rede, also erstmal habe ich mir gewünscht, dass sie dann im vernünftigen Abendkleid erscheint, mit einer Hochsteckfrisur. Dann, dass sie die Rede unter Tränen hält, weil es ja schon eine Rehre ist, auch auf Englisch, also penetrant auf Englisch, it's a pleasure, it's a pleasure. Vor allem dann auch dieses, ich habe überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet Ding. Genau. Also dieses, ich habe nicht damit gerechnet und dann den Zettel aus dem Ausschnitt zu ziehen. Ja, der auch schon zerknittert ist. Und man sagt, der wurde sich vorbereitet, der wurde schon mal geübt, der wurde sich abends im Wohnzimmer schon mal hingestellt. Genau, diese Art habe ich mir gewünscht, davon war nichts zu spüren. Es gab wohl lediglich eine kurze Frage und ja, wir haben den Podcastpreis bekommen, das hat uns sehr gefreut. Eine Frage, ich stelle mir vor, bei der Oscarverleihung, Halle Berry gibt dir den Preis und sagt dann, und wie sind Sie zur Schauspielerei gekommen? Ja, weil so eine Ausschreibung habe ich und dann ... La da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da ich von an la da da da da da da da da da sofort einfach nach einem sass ja also ich hab da da ich bin so ein gag bei einer rede ganz schlecht ankommt wann das orchester einfach entscheidet fuck fuck fuck la la la la la la la Ja, ja, das stimmt schon, ja. I'm not a racist, but la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la lada-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da auch unter Stimme. Bis gleich. Bis gleich. Ihr hört jetzt Musik. Ciao. Herzlich willkommen zurück bei der Das Podcast UFO Show mit Stefan Tietze und mit Florentin Will, will, will, will, will, will, Will, Will, Will, Will, Will. Ich fühle mich gut, ich bin geschminkt, ich bin eine Schale geworfen. Merkt man einen Unterschied? Nee, gar nicht. Nee, du glänzt ein bisschen mehr und hast ein bisschen mehr unreine Stellen. So hat man ja früher in der Shakespeare-Zeit geschminkt, indem man einfach... Das ist eine Gurke aufs Gesicht gedrückt hat. ...einen schönen Speck. I'm in a pickle, da kommt das doch her. Nein, ein schönes Stück Speck, schönes Gesicht abgerieben, mit dem Speck und dann so Tonstaub, also so gemahlenen Ton, so roten Ton für die Wangen drauf gemacht. Deswegen gibt es auch das Sprichwort to ham up. Wirklich jetzt? Also sich aufbrezeln ist to ham up, wenn man früher jemandem Schinken ins Gesicht geschmiert hat. Leute, Shakespeare-Referenzen könnt ihr immer abholen, immer schickt Shakespeare an die Einzelne. Oder kommt das eher dann aus dem englischen Theater oder was? Ja gut, natürlich. Ja, ja. Klar, muss man ja gucken. Aber deswegen sind Sie ja heute hier, um Ihr Buch zu ham ab.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, richtig.
Naja, es ist eine ganz...
Die große Ham-Ablüge.
Ja, es ist eine ganz interessante...
Tut mir leid, das Buch ist nicht so lang geworden.
Nee, das wollte ich jetzt auch gleich fragen.
Ja.
Es gibt nur zwei Seiten.
Richtig.
Dafür sind die anderen...
Aber die Bindung ist schön.
...98 Seiten komplett aus Fell, also die können Sie streicheln.
Und wie gesagt, eine ganze Reihe an Illustrationen, die billig verfügbar waren, auch noch dran gehängt. Ja, wollte ich auch sagen, es ist nicht von Ihnen alle zwangsläufig, oder? Nee, aber es ist wirklich vieles dabei, also Drachen, Enten, da ist glaube ich wirklich für jeden was dabei. Warum die 30 Seiten Widmung am Anfang, das war ja auch ein bisschen... Viele Leute haben mir geholfen bei dem Buch, viele Leute haben mich inspiriert. Aber gab es da so viel zu helfen, es sind nur zwei Seiten, also... Ja, okay, das ist Ihre Frage oder haben Sie noch eine andere Frage? Nee, ob man mit dem Teil zwei rechnen kann. Ja, ich habe leider zugesagt für sieben Teile insgesamt und ich bin jetzt mittendrin in den Arbeiten für Teil zwei. Es wird eng, möchte ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also da möchte ich auch mit meinen Lesern ehrlich sein. Puh, also ich habe jetzt vier Zeilen und der Stoff wird dünn. Aber es gibt ja auch jetzt, sagen wir mal, in der Kunst Beispiele dafür, dass man, dass Teil zwei ganz anders angehen ist. Und vielleicht mal eine andere Richtung, eine andere Perspektive. Da gibt es aber bestimmte Möglichkeiten, um das nur auszuschmücken. Ja, leider nicht möglich. Also leider nicht, ist mir nichts eingefallen. To hammer up, das war's. Hammer, Hammer Time. Flo und den Willen, der Mut her. Dankeschön, dankeschön, vielen Dank. Es ist schwierig, ich würde mir nie zu trauen, ein Buch zu schreiben. Also ich habe großen Respekt vor sowohl Sophie Passmann als auch Julia Becker. Ich fände es schwierig. Ich habe jetzt sehr viel Lust. Naja, natürlich glaube ich, jeder hat Lust, ein Buch zu schreiben, aber dieses, du bist auf Seite 12 und du denkst, oh, ist das scheiß langweilig, ey. Die Figur ist zu Ende erzählt, der Asteroid ist eingeschlagen, ich habe schon drei Zeiterbränge gemacht. Ich bin in der Einbahnstrasse manövriert. Ich habe jetzt die Regeln des Universums schon so oft hin und her gebrochen und dann jetzt irgendwie so auf den Bösewicht gewechselt. Das finde ich so nett. Ich würde mir schon zutrauen. Ich glaube, ich würde meinen Ansprüchen nur, und das ist vielleicht auch die Definition dann von Zutrauen, nie gerecht werden. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich mir irgendwann 200 Seiten geschrieben habe und danach sage, geil, so gebe ich es jetzt ab. Niemals, niemals kann ich mir vorstellen, dass ich, und das, also, natürlich ist es bei allen Werken, die man halt irgendwie so macht und so, und von Künstlern, von denen man hört, wie sie an Dinge rangehen, immer so, dass sie sagen, man ist ja nie wirklich fertig und irgendwann ist halt die Deadline da und dann gibt man das Beste ab, was man in der Zeit geschafft hat. Aber bei so einem Buch, und ich hätte den Anspruch auf jeden Fall, irgendwie einen Roman zu schreiben und nicht dieses Kurzgeschichtenquatsch, den die alle hier machen. Aber das ist halt auch so zeitintensiv, ich weiß es nicht, mal irgendwann, irgendwann mal. Ja, schwer zu sagen. Es wurde ja schon zu viel geschrieben. Ich denke immer, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dir eine Geschichte einfällt, die nicht schon irgendjemand hat. Ich meine, es gibt wirklich Science-Fiction-Romanen Reihen, die haben 200 Teile und es gibt 200 Reihen. Ja, jede Geschichte wurde schon mal geschrieben, jeder Gag wurde schon mal gemacht, jedes Lied wurde schon mal gesungen. Auch zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt letztens den neuen Film von Jordan Peele gesehen, Us, wo ich mir auch denke, gerade das Horror-Genre ist ja auch durch diese Groschenheftchen und so und Gänsehaut und so, das sind ja Reihen, die haben 500 Bücher. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dir eine Horror-Premisse einfällt, also so ein Klassisches, die Puppe wird zum Leben erwacht, das Obst kann sprechen, es regnet Säure. Aber das sind ja nicht die Geschichten, das sind ja oft nur... Ja, aber allein so diese Prämisse, das ist ja wirklich... Also vor allem, wenn dann Jordan Peel diese Idee hat, geht ja, das kann man ja im Trailer sehen, ist ja kein Spoiler, es geht um Doppelgänger, allein, also liest er da nochmal alles durch oder interessiert es den gar nicht? Oder gibt es da so Horrorexperten, die man fragt? Es ist so schlimm, wenn Prämissen gleich sind? Es gibt auch viele Filme, die ähnlich sind, wenn wir ähnliche Prämisse und trotzdem alle cool sind. Aber läuft man da nicht in Copyright-Schwierigkeiten, dass wenn jetzt wirklich ... du schreibst ein ganzes Skript. Und dann hat es wirklich ja das halt Mr. Jakamoto in Asien vor 36 Jahren schon exakt so geschrieben. Weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dir, es gibt doch Begänger, wo kommen die her, ja wo werden die wohl herkommen, warum existieren die, ja wo, warum ... Geil, schon mal ein bisschen so so eine Schreibblockade und dann erfährst du, dass jemand schon mal eine ähnliche Geschichte geschrieben hat und dann kannst du den Film schnell gucken und dann siehst du, wie der aus der Situation rausgekommen ist, trotz drei Zeitsprünge und als Theoret auf der Erde und dann machst du es einfach genau so. Ist doch mega gut. Was kann denn ein besseres passieren? Nee, aber ich verstehe, was du meinst, aber ich glaube, das sollte man nicht reingehen. Ich glaube, ich würde mir nur nicht, ich würde nur nicht denken, dass ich so kreativ bin, dass ich mir was ausdenken kann, was die Welt noch nicht gesehen hat. Und dann denke ich mir, wenn jetzt schon jemand die gleiche Idee, und dann, ich habe ja keinen, mir fallen ja dann keine interessanten Charaktere ein. Ich sage, es regelt Säure, pass auf, das ist es jetzt hauptsächlich, so wie ich dir das Buch bekomme. Du Fussnote auch. Freunde, pass auf. Leute, ganz kurz, hier geht es jetzt die nächsten zehn Seiten um Säuren. Wenn euch das nicht gefällt oder irgendwie allergisch, weil ich keinen Bock auf das Thema habe, dann lasst es auch. Ich meine, mir ist kein cooles Ende eingefallen, sage ich gleich. Gleich von und weg. Vorwort, auch wie das Vorwort. Entschuldigung, Rechtfertigung. Das wäre mein Stil, so wirklich so ein sehr unselbstbewusster Autor, der immer wieder sagt, also jetzt könnt ihr noch aufhören, jetzt ist es wirklich. Und dann ist es eine Liebesszene und dann kam es zum Kuss und direkt danach, ja Leute, was soll man denn sonst, klar ist das Kitzel hier an der Stelle, aber was habt ihr denn gedacht, wie soll man denn sonst rauskommen? Also hier ist eine Reihe an Buchempfehlungen, wie ist die weiter? Ich habe drei Sachbücher über Bücher schreiben gelesen und an der Stelle kommt halt meistens der Kuss. Sorry. Und sie führte ihre Lippen an seine Lippen und an Lippen sich ihre Sorry. Ich weiß nicht, wie man küsst. Es tut mir leid. Es tut mir wirklich leid. Was ich ganz toll fand, aber jetzt mal die beiden Bücher, Alte, Weisse, Männer von Sophie und Das Leben eines der härtesten von Julia anfängt zu lesen, bei beiden noch nicht durch, aber
ich finde toll, dass man bei beiden so einen ganz
eigenen Stil raus erkennt. Und das finde ich
wirklich toll. Und da habe ich das Gefühl,
bei guter Arbeit war es
so ein bisschen möglich, aber ich hatte noch nie so
wirklich mal die Chance,
mich selbst zu verwirklichen oder meine eigene Stimme
wirklich nach draußen zu bringen.
Und das ist sowas, was ich in meinem Leben nochmal machen will.
Also entweder mit einem komplett eigenen Film oder mit einem komplett eigenen Buch und so.
Ich glaube, bis dahin bin ich unglücklich einfach.
Bis dahin glaube ich wirklich, muss ich ganz gut ernst werden,
aber bis dahin werde ich in meinem Leben nicht glücklich sein, bis ich das mal geschafft habe.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass dir das mit Guido gelungen ist?
Guido, ja, schon ein bisschen.
Also hat das nicht deine Stimme total?
Ja, schon so ein bisschen.
Aber wie gesagt, das sind nur zwei Seiten seiten für mich sehr gross geschrieben haben damals und ich weiss nicht ob das noch nicht cooler ist und befriedigender ist wenn man das mal über 200 seiten in areal acht macht wie ist das noch mal guido hebt ab guido regt sich auf ich weiß nicht wie die geschichte hies im echt zu sein ich sie ging nur noch um Guido, ich weiss nicht, gar mal in Kindergeschichten. Schaut mal auf der Pupupedia. Es ging um das Alien Guido, was ich dann im Park gefunden habe, auf einer Bank, aber stehend und nicht sitzend. Das ist schon, ohne Scheiss, tatsächlich ein bisschen immer noch mein Stil. Also ich glaube, dass immer noch so naiv in Anführungszeichen so einen platten, pragmatischen Stil ver. Er war im Schwimmbad, aber nicht schwimmend, sondern stehend am Rand. Ich habe ein paar Bücher jetzt in der letzten Zeit gelesen, die alle so einen ähnlichen Stil hatten. Ja, die klauen alle Guido. Ja, vielleicht habe ich Albert Camus mit Guido beeinflusst. Der klassische Guido-Stil. Kann man schon sagen. Er war im Flugzeug, aber es stand am Boden. Leute! Nee, aber genau das ist, und das hat mich sehr gefreut bei beiden, das ist ja bei weitem nicht klar und sollte man nicht als gegeben akzeptieren, dass das beim ersten Buch dann direkt so ist, dass die beide eine eigene Stimme haben. Und man hat das Gefühl, so wie ich Julia kennenlerne oder Sophie kennenlerne, haben die sich schon ein bisschen selbstverwirklichet jetzt damit.
Ich fand es auch immer im Autorenraum damals cool, wenn viele Autoren an Texten schreiben, man immer an Gags sehen konnte, von wem das ist.
Nicht unbedingt wegen der Punchline, sondern wie das formuliert ist und wo der Humor gesucht wurde in dem Moment.
Ich finde, das konnte man schon erkennen und das freut mich sehr und sowas finde ich immer toll.
Gänsehaut zum Beispiel bei Julia. Das sehr klassische Julia-Indikator ist Gänsehaut. Gänsehaut Punkt. Als Punchline. Ja. Oder halt oft im Text. Ich glaube, es wird auch 80 Mal im Buch erwähnt. Irgendwann ein bisschen ermüdend. Nee, ist okay. Das wurde auch nicht erwähnt. Ich meine, es ist ja der Stil, aber das ist so ein, da wird man in der Literaturwissenschaft in 100 Jahren noch sagen, ah ja, das ist doch Frau B. Ja, Gänsehaut. Gänsehaut. Genau, und das sind unsere Buchempfehlungen für heute. Das ist der große Literaturclub heute mal. Wir sollten mehr Bücher empfehlen und mehr Bücher lesen. Liest du viel? Ja, aber so ein bisschen ungeordnet. Ich habe ganz viele Bücher so bei der Hälfte. Und ich habe dann immer Bock auf ein Buch, lese dann 20 Seiten, habe Bock auf das nächste Buch, lese 20 Seiten. Und am Ende brauche ich bestimmt zehn Jahre, um diese 20 Bücher so bei der Hälfte und ich habe dann immer Bock auf ein Buch, lese dann 20 Seiten, habe Bock auf das nächste Buch, lese 20 Seiten und am Ende brauche ich bestimmt zehn Jahre, um diese 20 Bücher durchzuarbeiten. Das ist ganz unproduktiv. Dieses Dogma, dass ich keine Bücher anfange, bevor ich das andere nicht zu Ende gelesen habe. Ich hänge aber gerade in einem super langweiligen Buch und das ist dafür, dass ich drei Jahre nicht weiterlese. Ja, das ist, da stellst du dir ja selber am Bein, das ist ein Problem. Und ich denke immer so, ich habe gerade Bock auf das Buch, warum nicht lesen, weil sonst würde ich ja gar nicht das andere weiterlesen, aber ich verfange mich total, ich bin gerade im zweiten Teil von einer dreiteiligen Freud-Biografie, super krass, super umfangreich, aber ich freue mich, ich freue mich auf die Serie, bald kommt ja eine Serie zu Freud und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie die sein wird, was sie behandelt, weil es ist ja immer interessant, so ein Leben irgendwie einzufangen, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie die sein wird, was die behandelt, weil es ja immer interessant so ein Leben irgendwie einzufangen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ja, auch der erste ist, wo man sagt Bio-series, also nicht nur Bio-Pics quasi, also wo man sagt, das ist nicht nur ein Film, sondern der ist jetzt jemand, dem hat man eine Serie gewidmet. Ist auch cool. So Queen hat einen Film bekommen. Na ja, aber dieser Drogentyp da Film bekommen. Aber dieser Drogentyp da, El Paco, wie hieß der? Pablo Escobar. Pablo Escobar. Ja. Der hat auch eine Serie, der hat mehrere Staffeln bekommen. Der hat mehrere Staffeln bekommen, ja gut, mehrere schon. Aber ich will jetzt mal sagen, so im Vergleich zu Queen oder sagen wir mal Steve Jobs hat auch keine Serie bekommen. Auch nur Film. Marco Polo. Nur Film. Auch eine Serie. Ja. Ist der mehr Amazon Prime. Das darfst du auch nicht mehr sagen, jetzt haben wir besprochen. Ich hatte jetzt drei Tage lang frei und ich hatte jetzt ein Jahr lang nicht frei und jetzt hatte ich mal wieder drei Tage lang am Stück frei und ich wurde richtig nervös. Jeden Tag wurde ich so ein Punkt 14 Uhr nervös, weil ich dachte, was machen Menschen, wenn sie frei haben. Weil ich kann das nicht, ich kann nicht gut, aber da war ich auch noch nie gut drin. Also auch wenn ich davor meinetwegen nicht ein Jahr lang durchgearbeitet habe, man hat immer, ich war immer nie gut darin, frei zu haben und nichts zu tun und zu entspannen. Ich bin nicht gut im entspannen. Ja, ja, ich verstehe. Der Schlüssel zum erfolgreichen, ich nenne es mal Zeitverschwenden, ist es, sich immer etappenweise Dinge zu bauen, auf die man wartet. Zum Beispiel, ich kaufe eine schöne Mate, lege die ins Gefrierfach. Jetzt weiß ich, das dauert eine Stunde und 15 Minuten, bis sie fertig ist, bis sie perfekte Temperatur hat. Oh, wenn du dich vergisst, ich fühl dir zu viel Angst vor. Ja, ist ein Faktor. Problem. Aber tatsächlich, dann habe ich eine Stunde und fünfzehn Minuten Zeit, wo ich ja jetzt nichts noch mal was anfangen kann. So, und dann hast du ja diese Einstellung, aber du fühlst dich nicht schlecht, weil du ja wartest. Wie lange masturbierst du? Naja, weil du wartest ja auf was. Das heißt, du sagst, ich kann jetzt nicht weitermachen, bevor ich die Mate nicht getrunken habe. Das heißt, du hast ein gutes Gewissen für die nächsten 75 Minuten. Das kenne ich lustigerweise auch, weil man was zu essen bestellt. Ja, genau, zum Beispiel. Wir befriedigen einfach zu sagen, in einer Stunde kommt das Essen jetzt. Genau, und du kannst ja in einer Stunde nichts mehr machen. Ja, man kann 30 Serien anfangen. Ja, aber du bist von der generellen Verantwortung befreit, dass du jetzt alles Mögliche machen könntest. Weil kannst du ja nicht. Und das ist das Geheimnis, zum Beispiel waschen und dann sagst du ja jetzt in zwei Stunden ist die Wäsche fertig und so kannst du dich Stück für Stück bis in dein Grab hangeln. So kriegst du jeden Montag bis Mittwoch rum. Du, also wirklich, ich snack die weg, immer snackbar. Ich verstehe es, ist kein schlechter Tipp, glaube ich. Bei mir rattert es nur immer, ich denke mir, du musst jetzt am nächsten Projekt weiter machen, du musst über deine Zukunft nachdenken, du musst... Ich weiß auch nicht genau. Lass es mal locker, Stefan. Nimm mal ein Bart, mach mal eine Kerze an, guck dich mal um, schau mal aus dem Fenster. Wie wäre es denn mit einem Haustier für dich? Ich glaube, ich will jetzt nicht wieder die Wunden aufreissen, aber ich glaube, der Verlust von Jeff hängt bei dir noch irgendwie in den Knochen. Du du dich jetzt so, du suchst so nach einer Erfüllung, die dir Jeff gegeben hat, die dir jetzt fehlt. Also ich sag mal, für einen freiberuflichen Autor, das hört man auch in vielen Podcasts, wo Autoren interviewt werden, die meisten haben einen Hund. Weil der die halt in so einen Rahmen zwängt. In so einen, ich muss morgens mit denen gehen, mittags mit denen gehen, abends mit denen gehen und so. Und da fallen mir dann oft noch Ideen rein und sowas, man ist nicht allein. Das sind natürlich schon coole Sachen. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich halt so oft nicht da und weg, dass man sagt, ein Hund geht nicht. Ja, das ist blöd. Aber eine Katze, hat die nicht auch ihr eigenes Business am Laufen? Schon. Also die hat halt einen Job. Der Hund hat halt frei, genau wie du. Die Katze halt nicht, die ist halt voll berufstätig. Die geht weg, die haut ab für acht Stunden. Vögel sind mir zu aufgeregt. Kommt er wieder zurück. Ich kann mir dich nicht mit einem Hund vorstellen, würde ich gar nicht. Nee, null, oder? So wirklich so mit zu einem und dann kommt der so mit seiner Schnauze auf dein Knie und du so blablabla. Nee, der ist weg. Ja, wirklich. Einfach. Ich würde mir auch vorstellen, dass dein Hund bei dir zu Hause ein eigenes Zimmer hat und man grüsst sich so im Flur so. Wie ein WG-Partner, nicht ein Freund oder wie ein Partner. Nee, nee, wie eine WG einfach so. Und dann klopfst du sie an so, wärst du jetzt bereit für deine Wanderung, deinen Spaziergang? Und dann geht ihr kurz rum und dann verabschiedet man sich wieder, hängt die Leine an die Wand und dann ist auch mal gut. Brauchst du sonst noch was, nachts checkt man noch mal, brauchst du irgendwas oder solche? Ja genau, dieses brauchst du noch was, ansonsten bin ich jetzt in meinem Zimmer. Das glaube ich wäre für dich so ein Hundebeziehungsverhältnis. Ich würde ihm auch direkt abtrainieren, mich anzuspringen und sowas, direkt euphorisch zu sein. Ich würde ihn auf so ein kühles, auf so ein Sarkasmus-Level runterbrechen. Bei einer Katze weiß ich nicht, da habe ich immer Angst, dass sie mich durchschaut oder irgendwann erfolgreicher ist als ich, wo man auch sagt, die hat ihr eigenes Ding am Laufen, die arbeitet in ihren eigenen Projekten. Das stimmt. Nee, du hast gerade viel besser gesessen. Nee, sorry, ich muss meine Knie auch ein bisschen. Du musst sie wieder überschlagen jetzt. Nee, es tut mir leid. Mein Bein stecht vorhin. Ja, meine ist auch eingeschlafen. Wir sitzen wirklich extrem nah aneinander, muss man sagen. Es tut mir leid, aber das geht so nicht. Dieses Einschlafen ist auch so ein komisches Gefühl. Ja, man fühlt sich ausgeliefert der Natur. Man merkt, man ist nur eine Hülle. Ja, und man darf sich gar nicht vorstellen, was da passiert. Also ich habe das Gefühl, das ist dann so wie so ein kleiner Schlauch, wo halt alle Gefühle drin sind, so die Nerven. Und dieser Schlauch wird einfach abgedrückt. Und dann fühlt man einfach nichts mehr in dem Arm. Und man denkt sich, was? Aber ist es nicht, wenn man Adern, also dein linker Arm schläft ja ein, wenn du ein Herzinfarkt hast. Ja, auch weil da kein Blut, weil es nicht mehr richtig geblutet wird. Ist es nicht auch so, dass du eine Ader abklemmst, wenn es einschläft? Der Herzinfarkt hat nichts mit Blut zu tun, oder? Ist es nicht, dass es irgendwie unregelmässig schlägt oder so und dann halt der Rhythmus nicht mehr drin ist? Schlaganfall ist zu wenig Sauerstoff im Gehirn. Nee, ein Schlaganfall ist ein Gerinnsel im Kopf, ein Blutgerinnsel. Ja, deswegen zu wenig Sauerstoff. Deswegen zu wenig. Ja, ich wollte nur die Ursache klar machen. Du wolltest der OP noch mal sagen, dass du dich auskennst, Herr Doktor.
Wir brauchen eine neue, ich glaube, diese alte Techline, die wir da haben unter dem Podcast, wir brauchen eine neue.
Das Podcast-Uvo nagelt uns nicht fest.
Bitte, bitte nagelt uns nicht fest. Nageln Sie uns nicht drauf fest.
Keine Korrekturen bitte.
Ich weiß es doch auch nicht genau.
Aber es ist jetzt, jetzt ist mein Bein eingeschlafen, das ist echt so komisch, weil du, aber kann man das nicht irgendwie nutzen, wenn man das steuern kann, wenn man jetzt weiss, keine Ahnung, du hast jetzt enorme Schmerzen, dann das abzuklemmen, aktiv oder irgendwie sowas, wenn dir kalt ist? Aber das hat uns unser Lehrer damals mal erzählt, dass afrikanische Stämme, die keine Medizin haben, gar nichts, an grossen Kenntnissen, jemanden Schamanen, der ab und zu den Göttern betet und Aids wegbetet und man hat das Gefühl, ist das die beste Idee oder sollte man nicht mit mich anrufen.
Naja, anderes Thema. Ich wurde immer noch nicht angerufen.
Nee, man kann sich, wenn du links Zahnschmerzen hast, an einem Backenzahn zum Beispiel links, von dir aus gesehen, musst du deine Stefan links, ja, er ist links, musst du dir den rechten Arm zwischen Daumen und Zeigefinger, da gibt es ja dieses Schwimmhäutchen, das kannst du dir abklemmen und dann hast du keinen Zahnschmerz mehr links. Da hat sich der Körper einen Twist überlegt, deswegen ist nichts recht. Das ist ein Cheatcode eigentlich. Das ist wie ein Cheatcode, ja. Wenn du das abklemmstst und dann spürst du deine Zähne. Das ist dein Ernst? Ja. Und dann gibt es für jeden Punkt einen anderen Punkt, der zusammenhängt. Stichwort Akupunktur. Stichwort kompletter Bullshit. Stichwort, ich glaube, das ist schon wissenschaftlich belegt, mein Lieber. Stichwort, nein. Stichwort, die Japaner sind nicht, die sind clever. Die können das. Wirklich, das ist... Oh, da war ich noch nicht. Manchmal werden ja so Vorurteile bestätigt und man sagt sich, hm, nicht gut. Aber manchmal ist es so, noch ich bin eine Asiatin dermaßen schlecht Auto gefahren vor mir, naja, habe ich gesagt, okay, kann ja mal vorkommen, kann ja mal lustig, dass es das Klischee erfüllt. Dann, eine andere Asiatin steht vor mir in einer Schlange und dann hat sie ihre ganzen Sachen auf die Kasse gelegt und da war es irgendwie ein Betrag von 14,98 Euro.
und sie hat im Kopf vorher so schnell durchgerechnet, dass sie es ganz schnell aus ihrem Portemonnaie die perfekte Anzahl an Münzen rausgesucht hat.
Aber in so einer Geschwindigkeit, dass sie es vorher durchgerechnet hat, alle Sachen, die auf dem Kassenband liegen,
da ist sie sich in den Supermarkt gelaufen, hat mit ihrem Kopf dabei durchgerechnet, wie viel das kostet und dann direkt das so schnell rausgesucht, das konnte ich gar nicht gucken und so schnell weiss man auch gar nicht, welche Münzen, welche Summen haben, es war so schnell gerechnet und man auch sagt, ja, sowohl die positiven als auch die negativen Klischees wurden beide bestätigt, an einem Tag, das ist schon seltsam. Ich habe immer das Problem bei der Kassierer, ich bin auch immer sehr schnell, aber ich habe halt nichts passend, aber ich habe immer schon meinen Geldschirm in der Hand. Und es machen ganz viele Kassiererinnen und Kassierer so, dass wenn sie alles erfolgreich gescannt haben und dann aufs Geld warten, dass sie dann wegschauen. Meistens nach links die Bahn entlang sozusagen. Ja, um schon mal vorzusorgen, um schon mal das Differenzierungsmodul wegzulegen. Auch, aber auch einfach weggucken. So, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich ist es ihnen unangenehm, den Leuten dabei zuzugucken, wie sie dann irgendwie ihr Geldbeutel rausholen, aber ich halte ihnen immer schon den Schein hin, während die weggucken und dann sind immer diese zwei, drei Sekunden, wo die Person wegschaut und ich ja meinen Schein halte und ist dann so ein Hier bitte, und es passiert mir so oft. Du hältst ihn dann so noch näher dran. Entschuldigung, ich muss aber auch sagen, ich bin mittlerweile sehr gut auf die Fragen vorbereitet, die kommen. Ich sag direkt, ich sag schon Nein, bevor die Frage nach Payback kommt. Ich sag schon Nein, bevor die Frage nach, wollen Sie noch Geld abheben kommt. Immer direkt, Nein, Nein, Karte. Payback ist bei mir auch immer Nein, wo ich mir denke, warum eigentlich? Warum habe ich eigentlich keine Payback-Karte? Ist das... Weil die alle deine Sachen scannen. Deren Idee basiert ja darauf, dass sie von möglichst vielen Leuten die Daten sammeln, wie viel sie wo einkaufen, was sie einkaufen. Und was kriege ich dafür? Du kannst Punkte sammeln. Ein Payback-Rucksack. Die Karte. Du kriegst eine coole Karte und kannst Piep einmal machen an der Karte. Nee, du kannst dann Rabattpunkte sammeln und dann irgendwann kriegst du richtig viel Geld zurück. Aber da gibt es halt Daten ab. Alle Daten. Auf der anderen Seite deine Daten braucht man nicht. Na ja gut, Datenschutz ist eine Sache. Es gibt ja auch so super krass verschlüsselte Messaging-Apps und so, ne, also irgendwie, keine Ahnung, genau sowas. Und da habe ich jetzt auch mit einem, ein Freund von mir hat darauf bestanden, das zu benutzen, halt dieses super krass verschlüsselte und da gibt es so verschiedene Verschlüsselungsstufen und selbst mit dem bin ich nicht mal auf drei von drei, ich bin nur auf zwei von drei und der liegt da super grossen Wert drauf und wir schreiben uns halt ausschliesslich, wann wir das nächste Mal Pen and Paper spielen.
Wo ich mir denke, dafür haben wir jetzt wirklich einen hochverschlüsselten, die CIA beißt sich die Zähne aus an unserem Kontakt und denkt sich einfach so, 18 Uhr, er spielt den Schwarzmagier.
Zugriff, Leute, Zugriff, also ich, aber auf der anderen Seite, man kann sich auch nicht vorstellen, welche Art von Kommunikation man unbedingt schützen möchte, weil welche ist wirklich schützenswert, aber es ist, naja, keine Ahnung. Ich denke mir immer, das ist so diese klassische umgekehrte Psychologie, dass die CIA ja vor allem die Messaging-Dienste überwacht, die vor allem sicher gelten. Wenn du wirklich sicher sein willst, dann nimm irgendeine ganz billige, nimm Aldi-Message oder so. Und vor allem nimm die nicht Leute, die andauernd kommunizieren. Ja. Also die Leute, die andauernd kommunizieren, die haben ja wahrscheinlich was anderes am Laufen als eine sporadische Dealerei. Allein wenn du bei Google eintippst, bitte möglichst sichere Kommunikations-App hast du verloren, ist die CIA sofort auf deiner Spur. Aber die können die ja da nicht tracken. Ja klar, die haben da so einen Schlüssel. Du hast die Schlüsselgeste gemacht? Die häcken sich da rein. Klar, die klopfen das ab. Ich habe ja mit sehr vielen Dealern gesprochen, als Recherche für die Serie. Und es war wirklich lustig, weil, muss ich alles mal danach in Ruhe erzählen, weil ein paar Sachen davon auch in der Serie vorgaben. Aber es ist schon spannend, wie die kommunizieren und die meisten halt nach wie vor über Prepaid-Handys und die benutzen Code-Wörter für, aber sehr einfache, so ein Fuchs ist ein Fünfziger, Fünfziger und so was, also so sehr... Ein Fuchziger. Sorry, habe ich versprochen. Aber wie erfährt man es von dem Code? Wenn ich jetzt Kunde bin, kriege ich dann so ein Wörterbuch mit allen Codes oder wie? ich glaube das wird vorher besprochen. Aber wie erfährt man es von dem Code? Wenn ich jetzt Kunde bin, kriege ich dann so ein
Wörterbuch mit allen Codes oder wie?
Ich glaube, das wird vorher
besprochen mündlich, bin mir nicht sicher.
Jedenfalls hat der eine
immer seine Kunden gebeten, auch immer mal
sowas zu schreiben wie Liebegrüsse
aus Holland, von Melanie und mir,
einfach um das Gefühl
zu geben, dass da ein normales Gespräch am Laufen ist.
Und nicht immer nur, ich hätte gerne
einen Fuchs, wo man auch sagt, oh ja.
Okay, und du glaubst nicht, dass dieser Dealer einfach
Vielen Dank. Einfach um das Gefühl zu geben, dass da ein normales Gespräch am Laufen ist. Und nicht immer nur, ich hätte gerne einen Fuchs, wo man auch sagt, oh ja. Okay, und du glaubst nicht, dass dieser Dealer einfach nur ein bisschen einsam war und sich auf diese Art einfach ein paar Fake-Freundschaften. Du kannst auch gerne mal schreiben, was dir in mir so gefällt, also charakterlich. Und das ist wirklich nur, weil du willst, dass es sichere. Ja genau, einfach nur damit die Polizei nicht jetzt denkt, dass wir Drogen dienen oder so. Also wäre halt auch gut, wenn wir irgendwie so jeden Donnerstag zusammen abhängen. Wir können aber einfach eine verschlüsselte App benutzen oder sowas. Die sind da halt drin, so, die sind da drin. Und wenn wir halt jeden Donnerstag abhängen und ein kleines Bierchen schlürfen, halt irgendwie kurz die Porn zischen. Aber es reicht, wenn ich die schreibe, dass wir ein Bierchen zischen. Es wäre halt schon gut, wenn wir zumindest einmal im Monat uns treffen würden und dann halt wirklich, also nur lockere private Gespräche, Also jetzt nicht über die Drogen, wie gesagt, natürlich, sondern einfach lockere, wie geht es dir denn in der Beziehung und so. Und ich kann dir auch was ein bisschen von meinem Autorenprojekt erzählen, ich habe da so ein Tribut gerade. Ja, nee, ja, nee. Einfach wäre halt gut, du willst ja nicht, dass du ins Gefängnis kommst. Ich bin clean, danke. Okay, sind verhaftet. Oh, Twist. Wie gern triffst du dich mit Leuten, wenn sie sagen, hast du mal Zeit, Stefan, und ich sag, ja, wann kannst du denn, und die sagen dann, ich kann immer. Ja, das stimmt, du hast recht verloren. Ich will diese Leute nicht mehr sehen in meinem Leben. Ich täusche oft Termine vor, um nicht zu schreiben, ja, wir müssen jetzt halt irgendwann in den nächsten viereinhalb Wochen, müssen wir mal irgendwie zusammenkommen, wann kannst du denn? Ja, ich kann jeden Tag. Ich kann eigentlich komplett durchgehen von sieben Uhr morgens bis vierundzwanzig Uhr abends, jeden einzelnen Tag. Okay, ich schicke dir mal ein Dudel durch und du klickst bei Dudel jede halbe Stunde. Aber da möchte ich mal den Menschen sehen, der bei Doodle wirklich jeden Termin anklickt, an dem er kann. Ey, wir sind alle keine Heiligen, wir haben alle schon bei Doodle gelogen. Ey, ohne Scheiß, wir bescheissen. Selbst der Papst klickt sich am Samstagabend was rein. Ich gebe hiermit offen zu, ich habe schon bei Doodle so oft beschissen und auch manchmal Tage manipuliert dadurch, die es dann nicht geworden sind. Und deswegen funktioniert Doodle auch nicht, glaube ich meiner Meinung nach, einfach weil ich nicht jeden Termin anklicken wollte, sondern random irgendwo einen raus. Das war bei der, wo alle konnten und jetzt kann Tim leider nicht mitmachen. Ja, wir können jetzt leider nicht zur Beerdigung fahren, weil Stefan leider am Mittwoch um 16 Uhr keine Zeit hat. Kannst du nochmal mal sagen, was du da machst? Vielleicht kann man es ja verschieben irgendwie. Nee, da habe ich es, ähm, nee. Aber irgendwie ist es jetzt wirklich, wir haben jetzt den Sarg und alle ist bereit und der liegt jetzt im Kofferraum. Wäre halt echt blöd, wenn wir das jetzt ausfallen lassen müssten. Da habe ich dieses Treffen mit meinem... Der Pfarrer ist da, wir haben die ganzen Blumen und was hast du gesagt? Da habe ich dieses ... Warum kannst du denn nicht? Vielleicht können wir ja was machen. Der Blumenladen hat nur dann auf und da muss ich hin. Du musst zum Blumenladen. Weil ich für die Beerdigung Blumen ... Ja, dann steigen wir ins Auto, fahren wir davor hin einfach, kein Problem. Nee, können wir da nochmal ein Dudel machen vielleicht? Diese Einbahnstraße, die man sich klickt. Gefährlich, gefährlich.
Ich habe schon so oft Hermine vorgetäuscht.
Völlig willküren Daten. Du, ich habe
am Mittwoch zwischen 16.45 und 17.20
Zeit, danach halt gar nicht mehr.
Und wirklich, mir sind wahrscheinlich
schon grosse Projekte durch die Finger
gerutscht. Einfach, weil
ich versuche,
wertvolle Zeit vorzutäuschen. Meine Zeit ist nicht wertvoll. Ich bin sehr müde gerade und ich glaube, es ist zu wenig Sauerstoff in diesem Raum. Wollen wir mal kippen zumindest? Ich mache mal kurz die Tür auf. Halben Stunde beginnt die Sendung. Das ist immer so die Zeit vor der Sendung, wo so ganz viel Energie in der Luft liegt. Aber niemand weiß wohin damit. Ja, niemand hat mehr eine konkrete Aufgabe. Man macht ja oft, man plant ja diese Dinge oft, wir machen die Generalprobe und dann dauert es noch zwei Stunden und dann geht es los.
Damit, falls die Generalprobe länger dauert oder so.
Die GP, wie man sie hier nennt.
GP. Und dann gibt es noch diese lange Zeit, wo niemand mit was zu tun hat, aber alle so heiß sind, voller Energie, alle erwarten.
Und das ist immer eine ganz spannende Zeit.
Das stimmt schon.
Und ich laufe dann oft durch die Gewölbe hier, weil ich habe jetzt mittlerweile tatsächlich, darf ich vielleicht nicht so laut sagen,
ich habe den kompletten Vorrat an Smarties gefunden. Hier gibt es immer Smarties für die Gäste und so, gibt es dann so Schalen mit Smarties und ich frage mich, wo kommen die her? Die vegan? Nein, wo kommen die her? Ich vertic die her. Du verdienst die? Und in den Gewölben habe ich mal so gesucht und hinterher ganz viel Spinnenweben und Rattenfalten habe ich wirklich so tonnenweise Smarties gefunden. Das ist unfassbar viel. Ich glaube, das ist so, ich glaube, wenn hier irgendwie, wenn es hier irgendwie brennen würde, würde einfach so eine riesige Flutwelle an geschmolzener Schokolade einfach den kompletten Autorenraum überschwemmen und alle ertrinken. Und Max Bierheiz würde sagen, so wollte ich schon übersterben. Und es ist absurd. Es ist wirklich absurd. Wie zum Beispiel, ich habe in
meiner Wohnung wahnsinnig viele Fertignudeln und Jalapenos, weit, weit mehr im Verhältnis als
alles andere Lebensnotwendige, weil ich will eine ganz, ich weiß nicht, habe ich schon mal erzählt,
ich habe zum Thema Asiaten sind scheiße, ich habe ne ganz, das fand ich mein Wording,
das hast du vorhin gesagt, dass du uns rausgeschnitten hast, aber ich habe tatsächlich eine ganz
spezielle Art von Fertignudeln, die ich immer hole und die ist aber ganz schnell ausverkauft immer
Und ich glaube, dass du uns rausgeschnitten haben. Aber ich habe tatsächlich eine ganz spezielle Art von Fertignudeln, die ich immer hole. Und die ist aber ganz schnell ausverkauft immer. Und deswegen gucke ich immer, wenn die da ist. Und wenn sie da ist, kaufe ich alle. Alle, die da sind, egal wie viele es sind, es sind oft so 20 Packungen oder so. Und ich weiß, dass wenn ich jetzt nur zwei kaufe und am nächsten Tag wiederkomme, sind die anderen weg. Deswegen, sobald ich sie habe, kaufe ich alle. Und eines Tages war ich da, weil ich weiß ungefähr, wann die liefern, so Montag oder Dienstag, je nachdem, war ich da, Montag, geht's im Regal, leer. Komplett leer. Fuck, noch nicht geliefert. Scheiße, muss ich morgen nochmal kommen. Muss ich warten. Muss ich warten, setze ich mir meinen Stuhl hin jetzt hier, da kaufe ich halt noch so mal einen. Da stelle ich schon wieder dieser hohe Typ mit seinem Campingstuhl, der vor dem Nudelregal sitzt. Ist das ein Schlafsack? Was macht der denn denn? Das ist ein Neoprenanzug, was macht der hier? Ich habe einen weitergeschobbt, schönen Smarties in Korb und so alles. Geht zur Kasse, leg auf auf der Kasse. Was hat der junge asiatische Mann vor mir? Zwanzig Packungen von meinen Nudeln. Er macht genau das gleiche wie du. Er macht exakt das selbe ich.
Scheiss Asiaten.
Und jetzt dachte ich mir,
fuck, it is fucking on.
Weil jetzt gibt es zwei Leute in Köln,
die in diesem ganz speziellen Edeka jede Woche darauf warten,
das gesamte Sortiment leer zu kaufen.
Ey, das sind die, ich will wirklich,
ich würde es euch gerne empfehlen,
aber ich habe wirklich Angst davor,
dass der Standkampf wird. Ich würde würde jetzt nur aus Spaß wegkaufen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, deswegen, das hatten wir schon hier, die Plakettensache, da haben wir schon ganz viel Erfolg. Ja, da freue ich mich auf die, auf die Museumseröffnung. Das wird nicht in Asien-Nudeln fortgesetzt. Und es ist jetzt wirklich jede Woche für mich ein Wettrennen. Ich habe mittlerweile ein paar Runden gewonnen, ein paar Runden hat er auch gewonnen. Manchmal ist es wirklich so, man guckt dann auch mal, es ist alles leer. Und diese Nudeln werden nie einzeln gekauft, sondern immer alle. Und ich stand hinter ihm und ich dachte mir, wenn der wüsste, dass sein Erzfeind genau hinter ihm steht, weil ich weiß, wer er ist. Dann würde er sein Ninja-Wurfmesser rausnehmen. Ich weiß, wer er ist, aber er weiß nicht, wer ich bin. Bis jetzt, falls er den Podcast hört. Das ist wie diese Family Guy Chicken Fights. Das ist ein Erzfeind. Das ist wirklich mein Erzfeind. Wenn ich den irgendwann mal sehe und man geht zusammen so durch die Lichtschranke und ich weiß genau, wenn der vor mir am Regal ist. Du guckst ihn an und beide springen los. Von oben und unten kommen die schwarzen Balken. Und er ist deutlich schneller.
Ja, wesentlich schneller. Ich bleib stecken.
Bleib stecken und er ist deutlich schneller.
Aber mittlerweile habe ich einen krassen Vorrat davon.
Ich glaube, ich habe 50 Packungen oder so auf Vorrat.
Ich bin bereit, weil man weiß ja nie, wann Dinge einfach abgesetzt werden. So geht es mir auch ein bisschen
mit Trüffel.
Ich erkenne dich nicht wieder, Stefan. Wirklich.
Nee, ich mag, du kannst lustigerweise, in Supermärkten kannst du ganz selten, ich mag Trüffel einfach gerne. Es gibt das eine Nudelgericht, was ich gerne mache. Das ist eines der wenigen Gerichte, die ich gut kochen kann, wo ich auch behaupte, auch Leute, die gerne essen, würden das auch gerne essen, das Nudelgericht, was ich da mache. Und das mit Trüffel. Und das gibt es so selten im Supermarkt zu kaufen,
dass immer wenn es da ist, und das hält einfach
ewig, das hält fünf Jahre, Trüffel.
Das heißt, man kann es
ewig stehen lassen bei sich.
Und deswegen kaufe ich das auch immer ein.
Aber das sieht bei Trüffeln immer ein bisschen sehr
seltsam aus. Aber was zahlst du
denn da auf einen Schlag?
Ja, schon mal so, manchmal so 60 Euro an Trüffel.
Das ist halt wahnsinnig teuer, aber auf der anderen
Seite hält es ja auch ewig und ich brauche es nur
einmal, diesen Erfolg.
Ich bin der Fall. dann da auf einen Schlag? Ja, schon mal so, manchmal so 60 Euro an den Pfiffen. Das ist halt wahnsinnig teuer, aber auf der anderen Seite hält es ja auch ewig und ich brauch's nur einmal diesen Erfolg. Ich hätte echt mal gern so ein Kuchendiagramm, wofür du dein Geld ausgibst. Also wirklich einfach mal so, dass sich mal so ein monatelang Detektiv verfolgt, der wirklich penibel aufschreibt, was du Geld ausgibst und dann so ein Kuchendiagramm. Ich glaube, es ist zu 80 Prozent vermeidbarer Bullshit. Ja, es ist aber die Frage, ob nicht alle Menschen vermeidbaren Bullshit Geld ausgeben. Nicht unbedingt, ich glaube Trüffel ist vermeidbar. Es ist schon die Frage, ob nicht alle Menschen. Ja, Sauerstoff ist vermeidbar, okay. Sechs Flaschen Sauerstoff pro Woche, da kann man drauf verzichten, ist klar. Gut, Stefan, tolle Meinung. Ich fliege jetzt am Samstag, fliege ich nach Cannes. Oh ja, da muss ja leider tatsächlich unser Live-Podcast ausfallen. Ja genau, da muss unser Live-Podcast nicht deswegen. Ja, das hätten die Zuschauer schon eins zu eins zusammenzählen können. Ja, ob es jetzt deswegen ist oder weil du da dein Tennis-Camp hast an dem Wochenende. Nein, ich glaube, alle gönnen, ich glaube, alle, die vielleicht auch leider nicht zum Ersatztermin kommen können, gönnen dir auf jeden Fall, dass du mal nach Cannes fliegst. Ist so sehr leid, aber die Serie... Vielleicht den Preis zu bekommen, der zweite Preis in einer Woche, zwei Wochen. Ja, ist ja, glaube ich, sehr unwahrscheinlich, weil sehr viele, sehr gute Serien laufen da. Aber zehn Serien und wir sind im offiziellen Wettbewerb und feiern da unsere Weltpremiere, was sehr toll ist. Und ich fliege mit meinem Chef, unserem Produzenten hin, weil der Pilot ist. Und wir fliegen halt in so einem ganz kleinen, in so einem Flieger, den man aus den Nachrichten kennt. Ja, also er ist Hobbypilot. Den man als Wrack aus den Nachrichten kennt. Damit fliegen wir da hin. Den man aus Filmen kennt, wo Koks geschmuggelt wird, kennt man diese Flieger. Aber primär aus Nachrichten, wo Todesopfer auch eine Rolle gespielt haben. Naja, und da fliege ich hin und freue mich da sehr drauf. Wie viele Sitze hat der Flieger? Fünf Stück, aber man sollte nur mit vier Leuten fliegen. Wir alle mussten unser Gewicht angeben. Und deshalb bin ich der erste Mal, wo ich dachte, weil man bescheisst immer beim Gewicht. Man bescheisst immer beim Gewicht. Klar, das ist die Regel. Aber da dachte ich so, nee, ich sage eben das richtige Gewicht. Ich sage eben, weil es ist
immer die Frage, müssen wir
zwischenlanden
oder schafft man es ganz nach Cannes?
Und wie lange fliegt ihr da? Dreieinhalb Stunden.
Und man kann wirklich einfach so
schnurstracks mit seinem eigenen Flugzeug
fliegen, drei Stunden lang?
Genau, du musst vorher ein paar Formulare
runterladen und ausfüllen für eine Landeerlaubnis und musst dann auch die Vektoren geben lassen und so weiter.
Du musst das vorher anmelden, dein Flug.
Also die geben dir dann eine Route, die du fliegen darfst, oder wie?
Am Flugtag aber dann erst. Sonst musst du aber trotzdem alles vorher anmelden und auch die Route mit der Flugsicherung besprechen und so weiter.
Ihr fliegt aber nicht so hoch wie Linienflugzeuge.
Viel, viel niedriger, viel niedriger. Und der hat es aber erzählt, deswegen kam ich gerade auf, der hat neulich immer eine Sauerstoffflasche an Bord ist.
Falls du mal so hoch fliegst, dass du einen Sauerstoff brauchst.
Damit man nicht wieder ein bisschen runterfliegen muss, kann man da auch einfach bleiben.
Der Kabinendruck muss ja aufrecht gehalten werden bei einer Boeing oder einem Airbus A23 oder sowas, mit dem man fliegt.
Aber bei diesen kleinen Maschinen geht das halt nicht, die haben keinen Kabinendruck, deswegen muss man dann Masken aufsetzen, wenn man zu hoch fliegt. Das kennt man ja auch dann von Düsenjets und so weiter aus Filmen. Und er hat die getestet und die ist einfach in die Luft geflogen und plötzlich ging es aber allen Leuten im Raum, wo er das ausprobiert hat, sehr gut, weil man sehr viel Sauerstoff einatmet und dann ist man sehr wach und sehr hell und sehr klar, alles ist cool. Aber das hat mir ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht. Es gab viele rote Flaggen auf dem Weg hin, jetzt schon. Viele Dinge, der Propeller war kaputt zwischenzeitlich, die Sauerstoffflasche ist in die Luft geflogen, es gibt keinen Sauerstoff mehr an Bord. Und es fliegt nur ihr zwei, oder was? Zu viert insgesamt. Zu viert, okay. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, ich habe schon Shotgun gerufen, um auf dem Beifahrersitz zu sitzen, Beifliegersitz zu sitzen und ich darf eine Playlist mehr aussuchen, weil es gibt tatsächlich, mit der erste Frage, gibt es ein Aux-Kabel für Musik? Ja, gibt's. Es wird nur andere unterbrochen, wenn Fluglotsen aus der Ukraine und so weiter einem reinbabbeln, aber da freue ich mich schon sehr drauf. Und das hört man dann aber auf den Kopfhörern, es gibt keinen Kabin in den Boombox. Ja genau, und ich ahne schon, immer in den Refrain rein, immer in den Refrain rein. Und was hast du so für Songs? Viel Top Gun, eigentlich der Top Gun, Top Gun Soundtrack. Die Playlist ist der gesamte Podcast. Fly With Me, Fly Me A River, No Woman No Fly, Fly May, Fly Away? Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, ihr gewinnt und dann Matthias einfach ein Sektglas nach dem anderen und du bist immer nervöser in der Ecke. Ja, man darf auch trinken, da habe ich mich auch gefragt. Man darf ja, bevor man Autofahren darf man ein Glas Weiswein trinken. Ja, wenn du nicht rausgewunken werden willst, darf man irgendwann... Sie fliegen Schlinger hier! Da wird man so rausgewunken. Ah, scheiße. Ja, aber muss man rechts ranfliegen und dann steht da nebenan so ein Polizeiflieger her, der so eine Kelle reinhält. Und man muss nicht in Sicherheitskontrolle, wenn man mit so einem Privatflieger fliegt. Das heißt, wenn du einen Terroranschlag verüben wolltest, immer Privatflieger fliegen. Na gut, du kriegst halt keine Genehmigung für Route von Start in Neukölln zu World Trade Center. Kriegst halt keine Genehmigung. Wo wollen sie nach New York oder was? Nee, ins World Trade Center. Wie ins World Trade Center, da ist keine Landebahn. Nee. Sie meinten New York, ne? Die schlafen im World Trade Center, aber sie wollen nach New York. Ja, genau. Aber halt schon rein direkt. Ja, okay. Ich schreibe einfach mal La Guardia auf. Gibt es denn Sicherheitsgurte? Das weiß ich nicht. Also muss man sich anschnallen? Ich glaube ja. Und Helme? Helm nein. Kein Helm? Nee, wie kein Helm. Wenn der Abstürzt ist, ist eh egal. Naja, ich meine, du fliegst jetzt nicht wie ein Stein ab, sondern du segelst ja. Wenn der Motor ausgeht, dann kann man immer noch segeln. Es gibteln. Es gibt keinen Helm, auch keine Sicherheitswesten, wenn ich über ein Wasser fliege. Ich würde lieber am Wassernotlanden, als auf dem Land, um ehrlich zu sein. Ja gut, aber dann bist du halt mitten im Wasser und verhungerst. Nee, aber das sind so Westen an und die bleiben dann oben. Nee, genau sowas gibt es nicht, aber es gibt wie gesagt ein Auskabel, es gibt alle Instrumente, bei mir auf der Seite auch nochmal. Das heißt, ich kann auch selber, ich habe meinen eigenen Höhenmesser, meinen eigenen, das ist ganz geil alles. Immer so als Prank so ein bisschen nach unten steuern. Und ich habe auch sämtliche, genau, ich habe sämtliche Hebel bei mir auch. Stefan, wir werden schon wieder was abgestürzt. Aber du hast den ganzen Flug deine Hand an einem Eumel. Ja. Es gibt keinen Autopilot oder sowas. Nee, es gibt Autopilot. Und ich mache einmal Zero-G. Richtig? Nein. Einmal ein bisschen runter. Aber auch Looping? Ne, Looping geht, ich weiß nicht, ob es geht, aber einmal so ein bisschen einfach mal Zero-G. Ihr stürzt sowas von, aber direkt ab. Und dann müsst ihr den Preis gewinnen, weil dann ist alles irgendwie so, ah, die Gestorbenen. Es gibt schon klare Regelungen, weil das ist natürlich Thema gewesen, schon in der Redaktionskonferenz. Natürlich wird uns dann die Serie gewidmet, zumindest.
Wirklich? Ja.
Im Ernst, das habt ihr durchgesprochen?
Ja, klar. Ja gut, aber dann wird es vier Leuten
gewidmet, die zu dumm waren, zu fliegen.
Naja, zu dumm waren.
Aber wird da der Pilot nochmal extra erwähnt?
Das ist die logische Konzeption. Vor allem, er hat mir so
casual nebenbei erzählt, er ist gerade in der
Killing Zone.
Und da habe ich gefragt, was heißt Death Zone?
Auf jeden Fall was sehr Makaberes.
Was heißt dieses Makabere Wort, was du gerade gesagt hast?
Er hat gesagt, er hat gerade so viele Flugstunden, dass bei Piloten so eine Art Routine einsetzt.
Und man nicht mehr vernünftig Checklisten durchgeht, weil man halt so viel Erfahrung schon gesammelt hat,
dass man es als gegeben wahrnimmt und fahrlässig wird. Da gibt es halt plötzlich so einen Einbruch, wo sehr viele Leute sterben, viele Piloten sterben und er ist mittendrin in dieser Death Zone. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es sehr gut zu wissen, dass es diese Death Zone gibt. Weil du dann wieder dagegen arbeiten kannst. Ja. Aber wie kommt man aus der Death Zone raus, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade einen Unfall baut oder so? Indem du so viel Erfahrung gesammelt hast, dass du wahrscheinlich gibt es da aus... Wenn du kleinere Turbulenzen hattest und merkst, okay, ich sollte mich doch ans Protokoll halten. Protokoll. Protokoll. Geil. Also wir müssen jetzt da auch ein bisschen Vorkehrungen kehren. Also du begibst dich jetzt in massive Lebensgefahr. Wie geht es dir mit dem Podcast weiter? Kann ich einfach mit Sophie Passmann weitermachen oder wie würdest du das... Nicht unter dem Namen Podcast UFO, gern The Podcast UFO oder La Podcast UFO, aber nicht unter dem Namen. Dann alle, die Hälfte meiner Einnahmen werden gespendet an irgendein Unternehmen deiner Wahl. Ein Unternehmen? An Siemens spendet das? Nee, zum Beispiel BMW oder Daimler oder Bosch. Du bist ein herzensguter Mensch, der war neil, weil du spendest dann Bosch. Ja, Bosch oder halt meinetwegen auch AEG oder Miele oder so. Eine gute deutsche Firma. Alles klar. Die Hälfte meiner Einnahmen und dann spendest du die Hälfte deiner Einnahmen. Warum? An Kinder aus Piet. Er wollte es so. Aber wie sieht es denn aus mit deinem Trüffel? Also jetzt, natürlich, Gott bewahre, solltest du jetzt wirklich was zustoßen. Mein TT-Trüffeltresor kannst du zu Hause. Was ist das Passwort für dein Trüffeltresor? Das ist mein Geburtsdatum. Alles klar, gut. Okay. Da kommst du dran. Und auch wieder die Hälfte des Trüffels geht direkt an Daimler. Abosch. Der Rest kann ich haben. Warum einfach so eine lächerliche Summe spenden an so ein gutes Unternehmen, wo man sagt, schön. Aber dürfen die Spenden annehmen? RWE, einfach mal. Also es ist wirklich einfach mal so 75 Euro an Toshiba. Und die sagen dann, ja, okay, Toshiba. Dürfen Firmen Spenden annehmen? Ja, klar. Nein, ich glaube nicht, weil damit kannst du ja dann Steuerbetrug machen. Deine Geschäftskunden spenden dir Geld, anstatt dir einfach normal zu bezahlen. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Spenden musst du ja auch absetzen. Anderes Thema. Spenden musst du ja auch versteuern, das meinte ich. Ich habe gerade zum ersten Mal im Leben gemacht, dass ich das Steuerabsetzen von der Steuerabsetzung nicht richtig verstanden habe. Stefan dachte, wenn man was von der Steuer absetzung, dann zahlt der Staat dafür. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Der zahlt es und schenkt es dir. Nein, Beispiel. Da kommt dann vom Finanzamt und sagt, ach, Sie hätten gerne diesen Laptop. Ja, dann gehe ich doch zum Mac Store, kaufe Sie den Laptop von Steuergeldern und bringe ihn bei Ihnen zu Hause vorbei, Herr Tietze. So funktioniert von der Steuerabsetzung. Nein, ich dachte, das von der Steuerabsichtung heisst. Also, ich fahre, also, 10.000 Euro bekomme ich, eingenommen. Dann zahle ich meinetwegen davon 5.000 Euro Steuern. So, jetzt bin ich aber mit dem Taxi gefahren. Für vier Euro. Für fünf Euro, um es ein bisschen einfach zu machen, kurz, mit dem fünf Euro mit dem Taxi gefahren. Jetzt kann ich das noch von der Steuer absetzen, von dem 5000 Euro, die ich eh gerade bezahle. Das heißt, ich muss nur 4995 Euro zahlen. Nein, du musst nur Steuern auf 9995 Euro zahlen. Das heißt, die Hälfte davon. Also dann 499... Aber warum kriegt man dann manchmal Geld zurück vom Finanzamt, wenn man... Ja, weil es ja das Finanzamt ja noch nicht weiss, dass du mit dem Taxi gefahren bist. Und erst wenn du deine Steuererklärung machst, erfährt das Finanzamt, ah, du bist mit dem Taxi gefahren. Und dann kriegst du was zurück. Also ich krieg das nicht geschenkt. Nein, du kriegst es nicht geschenkt. Und es fährt auch kein Mitarbeiter vom Finanzamt bei dir im Taxi mit, Stefan. Das haben wir jetzt wirklich schon hundertmal geklärt. Du musst dann nicht anrufen und sagen, so, ich bin jetzt bereit, ich stehe vor der Tür, ich hupe. Hören Sie die Hupe? Ich bin's. Ich bin jetzt da für das Geld. Na gut. Das funktioniert nicht, ey. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich muss jetzt ganz dringend nach Hause meine Finanzen klären, kann man ehrlich zu sein. Und ich habe neulich gemerkt, dass ich ähnlich falsch beim ganzen Leben Netflix und chill verwendet habe. Ich dachte nicht, dass es Sex ist. Was dachtest du denn? Netflix und chill. Chillen und Netflix gucken. Und warum sollte es dafür extra ein Wort geben? Weil es so cool klingt, Netflix und chill. Ohne Scheiss, ich habe letzte Woche zum ersten Mal erfahren, dass es da um Sex geht. Und wie oft warst du schon in der Situation und sehr überrascht? Jetzt muss ich mich bei sehr vielen Menschen entschuldigen, denen ich, also wo ich viel zu früh... Ey, hast du Bock auf Netflix und chill die ganze Nacht, ey, drei Staffeln? Ja, aber auch so bei der ersten Nachricht, wo man sagt, unangebracht. Aber ich meine, du hast ja jetzt eine Netflix-Serie geschrieben und dir ist schon klar, dass viele Menschen deine Serie anmachen werden, nicht um sie zu sehen. Sondern um rumzubumsen., sondern um rumzufummeln. Rum zu vögeln. Und der Dialog, den du wirklich mit feiner Feder über Monate lang verfeinert hast, läuft einfach im Hintergrund, während da zwei Jugendliche schön sich gegenseitig durchwingeln. Durchmösern. Ja, das ist nicht gut. Das ist dir schon klar. Finde ich ist Netflix keine Kunst oder irgendwie. Geschichten erzählen ist einfach nur Hintergrundrauschen, während man irgendjemanden abschlägt. Ich werde es auch hassen, wenn ich dann höre, dass Leute sagen, nach der ersten Folge ist es nicht für mich. Das ist halt immer Kacke. Das tut mir auch mal leid. Aber Stefan, du darfst halt auch keine Serie schreiben, die erst bei Folge 8 gut wird. Ja, ja. Das ist ein merkwürdiges Konzept. Das ist ein bisschen das Problem.
Naja, wir gucken mal, ob die Jurorin kann, das genau. Du darfst halt auch keine Serie schreiben, die erst bei Folge 8 gut wird. Das ist ein merkwürdiges Konzept.
Das ist ein bisschen das Problem.
Naja, wir gucken mal, ob die Jurorin kann, das genau so sehen.
Ob du überhaupt überlebst, bis nach...
Stephen Fry ist in der fucking Jury.
Stephen Fry hat deine Serie gesehen?
Er wird meine Serie sehen.
Alter!
Stephen fucking Fry, da freue ich mich mega drauf.
Aber ganz kurz, da ist jetzt die Premiere und wie viele Folgen laufen dann da?
Zwei nur leider.
Die ersten zwei?
Ja, okay.
Leider nur zwei immer. Und wer ist
da in einem Kino? Also alle, die da in diesem Film
ist. Oh, das ist ein riesen fucking Kino.
Das ist ein riesen Kino. Alter. Also das ist lächerlich.
Und da siehst du auch das erste Mal die Folge dann wirklich
fertig, oder? Ne, ne, ne.
Aber ja, zum ersten Mal
glaube ich in der final
composited Version.
Aber auf Englisch oder wie oder mit Untertiteln?
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, wie es jetzt ist. Ich glaube, es ist aber original mit französischen Untertiteln. Und für Stephen Fry eine englische Version. Du wirst uns alles davon erzählen, falls du es überlebst. Toi, toi, toi, schreibt eure Glückwünsche in die Kommentare, dass Stefan bitte überlebt, um diesen fantastischen Podcast. Ich hoffe es. Die beiden Live-Folgen werden sehr unangenehm, wenn du jetzt wirklich stirbst, aber dann springt Thais ein, glaube ich, die kriegt das.
Ja, Thais kriegt das besser hin, glaube ich auch.
Macht's gut, haut rein, vielen Dank, bis nächste Woche.
Und ich würde mich nochmal für das Leben, was ihr mir bislang ermöglicht habt und wie ich toll gemacht habe, bedanken, es macht jede Woche viel Spaß.
Macht's gut, lest ein Buch, bis nächste Woche, ciao, wir haben ab.